hello and welcome to the eighth PHP
tutorial this is going to be discussing
arithmetic operators so we're gonna just
start a new and let's go over real
quickly the operations that we can do so
to start we have all of the typical ones
you've got addition subtraction
multiplication division you can also get
modulus for the remainder with
percentage sign and then you have plus
plus equals increment increment up by
one and then you've got - - which is
basically increment them down by one but
you can also do things like + equals so
you can say like 1 1 + equals 5 or
something but later on I'll show you
more but like let's say you had a
variable called num and that was equal
to 10 you could say num plus equals 5
something like that and it just adds 5
to the num variable so let's show some
real examples of this so let's say let's
do so add is just going to be 10 plus 20
then we'll define another one we'll call
subtract equals 20 minus 10 then we'll
do multiply equals 10 times 20 multiple
anyway in divide is going to equal 20
divided by 10 and then let's say we want
let's just go ahead and echo out that
stuff real quick so echo and and then
we're just going to append breaks
to all of these so we can see the
difference and I'm just gonna copy and
paste this
I mean break so we can do this really
quick actually let's do the whole line
and I'll just change alright here we go
let's subtract multiple and about so now
we'll save this and we'll put it up on
the server over here run horse error
line three do not add it oh gosh I'm
gonna do it on any of these pane there
we go so now you've done all the math 30
10 200 - let's make sure yep 10 plus 20
is 30 20 minus 10 is 10 200 that's good
and then obviously - great so what else
can we do well another thing that you
can do is some math so let's say we want
to do 30 and we'll do times 10 so we can
take these variables because you don't
have to just use numbers you can do it
with variables so let's do echo add
times multiple save and we'll throw this
and now you can see we echoed out 30
times 200 equals 6,000 now of course we
can do the same thing we can you know
divide here put that over and you see we
have decimal there point 15 and so on so
of course you can do this with variables
as well now the last thing I'm going to
really show you is kind of arithmetic
rules for example so what we're gonna do
is echo we'll just do 5 plus 3 divided
by 15 so in your head you might be
thinking that's going to be 8 divided by
15
but what's going to happen due to the
rules of mathematics is it's actually
going to be five plus three divided by
15 so if you wanted to break down easier
that's what's gonna be output so let's
go ahead and show you that save it run
and as you can see yes it is indeed
it's 5.2 so what do we do about that
well if you haven't already figured out
when I showed you the parentheses you of
course are gonna put this so now it's
going to be 8/15 and we'll save that pop
over here refresh and now you've got a
much more the answer that you were
really looking for if that was the case
as you might have been looking for five
plus three divided by 30 but anyway you
can just use these parentheses no
different than you would with a
calculator to arrive at the proper
answer so finally let's discuss the
incremental so we'll say number decrease
equals ten and then number decrease
let's do X so let's use what we've
already used so we'll say add plus plus
so you're just adding to what exists now
we want to echo out ad so initially ad
was equal to 10 plus 20 so 30 and we
print out 30 here and now let's see what
happens when we call the plus plus as
you can see it outputs a 31 now what if
we change this to a minus minus say that
come over here refresh and you can see
it minus 1 from it
now there's a couple other things that
you can do you can do the plus equals
like I was saying so let's say plus
equals 50 so now it's going to do 30
plus 50 and we'll come over here refresh
and as you can see you gave us an 80 and
then finally you can do minus equals 500
what's a
come back over here refresh and I've got
a negative 470 so many ways those are
all the arithmetic operators how to use
them in time you'll probably use the
incremental one and then also basic math
is pretty much integral to a lot of
programming so as always thanks for
watching thanks for your support your
subscriptions and it's a nice thing